the the single greatest storyline in
heavyweight history was Francis and Gano
vs surreal gone finding out that they
were teammates that the coach had to
make a split the manager made a split
they moved away those and it was
projected to do 1.2 million just to
share for you it did just over 300 000.
it was the biggest flop uh of last year
and it was a stunning thing to watch it
flopped because those guys refused to
tell a story neither one of them wanted
to me they were focused and they were
telling them whatever it was we barely
sell out the arena nobody watches on
pay-per-view and then Francis wants to
turn the gun on the on the company and
act like I'm gonna walk away and go
fight Tyson Furious what difference does
it make if you do nobody's tuning in to
watch you fight I don't know if Dana
will ever have a better story for
Francis than he had with surreal I just
those don't come along very often but
he's supposed to turn it into a bigger
fight I mean of course she of course you
let the guy walk I mean I think the
story with Francis is just being the
most destructive human being on the
planet and I don't know how much more
you need after that sure you know like
even the early Tyson days it's like this
guy's gonna just devour somebody and I
think that's what we started seeing with
Francis and uh his backstory is cool too
oh his backstory is great and it's sweet
but I hear what you're saying it's like
nobody wants to sweep backstory yeah
they want to see the blood boil a little
bit so how do you make the blood boil
yeah and we can say it's sweet and great
we can do those things to be nice it did
300 000 on a projected 1.2 like we don't
have to pretend to be nice he sucks as a
draw that's the truth well
is that why they let him go
yeah I mean at some point what are you
going to do 1.2 they're gonna cut the
[__] check absolutely cut it for
Connor 100 100
I mean I'm just sharing for you like we
need to sit back and be nice because we
here here's what your numbers are here's
the opportunity you had with the single
greatest storyline in history and here's
what your numbers were here's also how
many times you went on ESPN how so many
times you went on wrong house how many
times you sat down with Andrew there's
ways to look at what you did to create
that number and he and surreal took
their ball and went home
that's just the truth I don't know why
surreal at one and one is getting put
back in the main event when you can't
count them anyway what are you gonna do
surreal becomes your Champion you
already had that problem you're gonna
stop selling tickets in the heavyweight
division who would you put there well
that's why they're in a tough spot right
now I would have liked to have seen uh
Stipe I don't think his time's done but
I know that clock's ticking I know he's
he's close to 40. I think he's he's over
it and I know that that clock's ticket
I'd like to see Francis get back in
there that would be my prediction what
happens with Francis next my prediction
is that that he comes back home I think
that Francis versus John is something
really special and other than that I
mean the heavyweight why is that special
What's the storyline
Francis being as big as he was France is
barely making the lemon we don't have a
lot of big guys in boxing either until
the klitschkos came along or now Tyson
Fury we've really never had anybody that
was a really big guy size was always a
disadvantage
and a size Advantage Mike Tyson never
had the longer arm and he never weighed
more than a single opponent yeah I just
think that's interesting because it's
really not an advantage to have a longer
arm it's really non-advantaged to way
more but we continually call it one so I
only bring that too because it is
something interesting about Francis okay
he's got this destruction okay just on
signs alone we know size Matters he hits
something he can destroy it all of those
lines then he takes on Jon Jones who was
a a National Collegiate wrestling
champion Jon Jones seems to be one
takedown away from taking everything
from Francis but Kenny take him down
it's an interesting one piece because
according to John No according to John
himself I'm not big enough according to
John I will not get in there I will not
even try until I get to a certain weight
which took him three years to do and I
think I think just that didn't nylon
refusal to fight Francis until he got
big enough that he was comfortable
fighting Francis makes for a Mystique of
Kenny B Francis and you also have
the pound for pound Great would you call
Francis the pound for pound oh no no he
was the best at heavyweight but no I
don't think he was very uh well okay the
most destructive person on the planet
there you go sure versus the greatest of
all time sure
everybody wants to see that for sure
actually yeah there's good story there
yeah and you can I mean I don't know if
he wants it but you could make Jon Jones
a heel against because there's no more
bigger face than Francis because based
on his story so even the failure of the
cereal gone fight is somebody who's I'm
admittedly big novices UFC I would say
isn't that on the heel to carry that
fight because this guy's the face yeah
you beat the heel if you're gone now you
gotta [__] now you're cooking I love
what you're saying I don't I don't
disagree with any of that and Francis is
you know you guys come that you know
historic boy it that almost brings a
tear to your eye when you hear what he
went through to get here like that that
is such a lovable story and I don't know
I don't know why he didn't Embrace
telling that more I don't I don't know
why he let that go I don't know why he
you know I feel like he shared it for
Francis to fight Tyson Fury is not a
draw just like McGregor to fight
Mayweather is not a drawer that's a draw
the sitting that's crazy well I'll tell
you this way and this is disagree with
me if I make this claim though McGregor
did not get paid to fight Mayweather the
simultaneous two division UFC champion
with Dan white in his Corner got paid to
fight melee I'm with you on that I think
Francis is more valuable to that Tyson
fight if he is the current heavyweight
champion yeah according Tyson said I
will box the UFC champion well now he's
got a guy that's not the champion yeah
yeah and if you ever want to see that
get spoiled Dana White grabs a
microphone one time and says Tyson if
you really want to do this here's John
Jones and I'll let you fight him Dana
says that one time well in France and no
one will ever say Francis his name again
and that's just the truth yeah but
Tyson's gonna absolutely obliterate John
and John's not going to do it and Dana's
not gonna do it I I get the play there
I'm just sharing you know this was a
this is a very risk there is value I
think we're undermining the value of the
UFC and France's promotion especially
since he might not be the greatest at
promoting himself outside of the sport
sure
hmm that's interesting so the longer
he's outside of the UFC the more the
stock kind of goes down it would see and
then the less interested Tyson is in the
fighting out Francis like I still think
Francis has a chance against Tyson to
beat Tyson yeah four rounds of gloves
okay with the four ounce gloves maybe he
connects but you're talking about I
think
and I'm a boxing fan I think there isn't
a heavyweight in history that could be
Tyson Fury I agree yeah sadly it's crazy
to say it isn't it and it's sad too
because it takes a Nostalgia wave but my
tigroup in the Mike Tyson era but Mike
is 5 10. no I'm gonna be Tyson like I
know and it's one of those things where
it's like it's hard to even formulate
the sentence where you go Tyson fear is
the greatest heavyweight boxer in
history but I think he is but you just
said uh size and reach doesn't make a
doesn't give you an advantage at six
nine yeah six nine versus Five Ten yeah
there's yeah there's a Tipping Point for
sure but but that's beautiful what
you're saying I mean if more people
thought that it's also from what I
understand Tyson's footwork is amazing
like Shaq just for his size that size
have feet like that it's crazy
it's just hard yeah I'm just but anyway
I would watch it I would but yeah we'd
love to see UFC versus boxing because I
think that we naturally have this like
curiosity about who are the most
destructive people and boxing has this
Legacy right and a huge Advantage within
their own discipline when the MMA guys
come in and they fight the boxers they
often lose